they say to women how many hours do you  work and they say to men how many hours  do you work the women work Less hours  self-reported but  I was because I need to go home and  clean a house and raise some children as  well as work in a full-time job because  of gender roles because of gender roles  I do a lot I'm not saying I have  children but hypothetically I do a lot  of unpaid child care I do a lot of  unpaid housework I do as well as a  salaried role so if we hypothetically  have the same job but he works more  hours is because he has a privilege to  work more hours and to put more into his  job and and climb the ladder because  he's a man who has male privilege